so hallo hier sind hi Frank tauschier
Filmkritik TV und Christop kchten von
klickom und wir melden uns aus West
Hollywood vom sunset Plaza Plaz mit
lecker Essen gerade war sensationell
aber sensationell ist franktausch komm
kommt zu klickum jetzt im Sommer Herbst
so im Bereich des videays weil da wirst
du auch sein würde ich wahnsinnig gerne
dabei sein ja auf jeden Fall der Hammer
so und was ist wenn jemand zum ihr könnt
i Fragen stellen so ist es bei Frank
Tausch auch in letzter Zeit nehmen wir
ja auch die Kommentare also kräftig
kommentieren Videoantworten Posten mit
euren Video Fragen und den Infotext
lesen und kreativ sein und das war's
eigentlich genau oder kannst auf den
Markt Spargeld überweisen Heiratsanträge
machen an mich nicht an ihn er ist
vergeben ja das war's okay also bis dann
bleibt dran tschüss aus
Hollywood